pro-democracy activists deliver a
petition to beijing's liaison office in
hong kong
they want the group of 12 held on the
mainland of china
to be released after more than four
months in detention
there's a secret trial you know people
are not allowed the family members are
not allowed
uh to go on to hear the trial out
and and also they have not met with
their family member
over the 128 days that they are detained
so then no transparency
no visitation by family it's all
harassment tight security surrounded a
court in the southern chinese city of
shenzhen
as 10 of the 12 activists attended the
first day of the trial
they are facing criminal charges
relating to last year's anti-government
protests in hong kong
and one of the accused has been charged
under the national security law
in august they were caught by chinese
authorities trying to flee hong
kong by boat they've now been accused of
illegally entering mainland waters
family members say they've had no
contact since their arrest
and were denied permission to attend
monday's court hearing in shenzhen
they now fear for their safety
i beg the courts to give the verdict as
soon as possible
i want to see my son again very much
the families of the 12 have been in
great agony throughout their detention
they are now only asking for the safety
of the children and their earliest
return to hong kong
the united states has demanded the
accused be returned to hong kong to face
trial but china has rejected that
request
accusing the us of interfering in their
domestic affairs
hong kong's chief executive says it's a
matter for the mainland
if these hong kong residents were
arrested
for bridging mainland offenses
then they have to be dealt with
according to
the mainland laws in accordance with the
jurisdiction
before any other things could happen
another nine people
in hong kong have been arrested
suspected of helping the group
flee the city in august they've been
accused of arranging transport
and the police here haven't ruled out
making more arrests
sarah clark al jazeera hong kong